this cannon shoots 100 arrows and this
is a freaking rocket launcher in
minecraft and this is the largest
minecraft sword ever it's kristin
chandler versus carl and nolan and
whichever team wins the most battles in
this video gets two ten thousand dollar
pcs and we're starting things off in
this ginormous arena and all the guys
are equipped with thor's hammer begin
the duel go trailer come on like right
oh they're already throwing
oh carl's getting wrecked you're going
down die
oh
oh my god we kill each other oh come
back
i mean i'm rubbing the hole
yeah this is your gaming debut nolan
don't suck no one sucks
i don't have my hammer anymore
nolan chris and chandler have one point
nolan and carl have zero and whichever
team loses gets pelted by mcdonald's
burgers you're going down nolan no
server spawn the lasers
oh my these lasers can break blocks hurt
each other begin
go go go i i'm going after nolan because
he's the worst i'm going after carl carl
do you see him
oh carl jacobs with this flank he's
going down i can get chandler out
i can't move
jayla is the type rope oh could i move
yes chris you left me i'm dueling nolan
i made him oh
yeah you better run nolan
[Music]
come on 1v1 now you can clutch this who
is the better gamer chris has more
health oh nice nice nice chris if you
lose you're bad watch this come on
got one one heart
oh oh my god it's nice nice nice nice
blue team has two points red team has
zero this is an arrow cannon that shoots
100 arrows and since red team is getting
stumped i'm going to give you both your
laser cannon and your thor hammer back
hey losing works sometimes go
all right listen nolan which one are you
better with i'm thinking i'm bad at
aiming so the crossbow is probably
pretty good yeah you use the crossbow
they're playing cautious too they
shifted all right use the building for
cover
oh shoot they're shooting the laser all
right i am shooting crossbows
ah i hit him i'm shooting up his cover
i'm getting rid of their cover okay
let's be aggressive
all right
oh he hit me i push push push all right
they're pushing they're pushing
yeah i know i'm shooting oh he's on me
he's on me i'm shooting him go for
chandler keep pushing with the lasers
i'm getting a kill this time i'm hungry
nevermind i'm pushing so hard right now
oh i got four hearts i don't need you to
kill you just can't die okay pushing
push and push him getting old he's
chasing me he's right here getting old
and getting all the nolan's down one
more one more get him
get over here they're two be one of me
they're almost dead
back up back up he's lazy and he's
lazing watch out this is jordan boyce
he's got you pinned in the tightropes
ah
oh he's just gonna use the laser like a
nerd what a nerd how much help is chris
on i need to kill chris wow
use the op weapon yes
with no handicaps at all kristin
chandler 2 carl and nolan won this
battle's op weapon is the mega sword
this thing's huge oh my god
carl i think you should sneak out of
your room and switch computers with
nolan oh that's a good idea
[Music]
you are now nolan
everyone take your ginormous sword and
start whacking each other go go let's go
whack him all right let's go
wait nolan twist chris go for carl
jacobs yep come on
oh my god i'm hitting him no one's
focusing me oh i'm down i'm down hard so
i'm down hard sorry chandler renting's
in the lead yo yo who turned the hacks
on he's on seven health six carl plays
minecraft so much he's sweating so hard
i'm gonna get chandler
oh carl's even back off back off back
off cheers at one no
i got chandler i got chandler oh no way
let's get him let's get him
we won carl plays this game every night
it is now 2-2 you have a 50-50 chance of
each walking away with a 10 000 pc or
getting pelted by mcdonald's burgers fun
the next weapon
whoa this weapon right here is a shotgun
but it shoots grenades have fun boys go
go go go go go go go go go nolan don't
follow me if you're not shifting i'm
shifting i'm shifting wow they're
shifting in a gun game when do you see
them now do you see their name tags you
gotta run are we are we attacking oh
yeah
yeah i got him once nolan up top up top
of the dock got carl all the good old
bait switch
nolan's flanking no got him no one's
dead oh my god are you kidding we're
pushing carl pushing carl i'm flaking
right i'm flaking right
got him again
oh what's up destroyed we're getting
free pcs chandler and they're getting
mcdonald's the next weapon is this
rocket launcher
you are all now standing on top of a
building in this beautiful city
character shreds have fun okay we're
gonna stay on the roof as much as
possible
boom
hey [ __ ] it jump up
yo i'm launching at him i'm shooting at
him
i'm going to give chris a little region
all right chandler chandler we got to
regroup
they're shooting at me we have the high
ground stay up here
whoever's on the roof just sniping me
you're dead to me come over here they
have the high ground and they're wailing
down on you i know
ah i hit him i hit him i hit him here i
was just gonna give you guys ladders
there's ladder sorry oh now i'm one shot
hey you guys should try to shoot a hole
under them so they fall
oh he's shooting up through the building
carl
i'm i'm ah girl got him girl
he rocket jumped to save him did you
fall in yes i fell in
oh
yeah
no one's so bad you're the only human
that'll lose on high ground go go go go
go go go go go go go go go go go go go
carl's here i see him hey how's he up
here now how's he up here
[Music]
oh nice nice nice
okay where is chandler oh he's on the
ground i'm shooting from above i'm
shooting from above oh okay they're
trying to double team i'm running away
go go go go go go go push push push push
push push i'll keep suppressive fire you
just keep pushing him if he hits me once
i'm dead one of them is pushing and one
of them is literally just shooting at me
i'm gonna try to pull away and then get
him alone
oh my god bad rocket jump come on
he oh he got me okay all right that's
1v1 now
[Music]
how does he have 13 health what
yes
yes i hit him so many times carl just
2v1 them yeah blue team has three points
and red team has three points wait that
means we're tied this is the final round
with max
mr red team can you please get in your
mix suit on what button do i press again
carl dolly can't even figure out how to
get in it
oh i mean all right i'm in store
nolan all the mac anime you watch
prepared you for this i don't watch mech
anime nolan push this way shut up about
anime ah i'm dodging bullets i need help
i need help i need help push back left
chris i haven't hit you a single time oh
bye take it back watch out all right
he's shooting all right i'm coming i'm
coming
it's carl's on me
hey trailer where are you i'm here oh
chris is getting double-teamed yo he's
getting messed up this is ours carl this
is us this is us
oh carl's is coming after you
i got some good ants i got some good
hits we got this car we got us in the
bag it's low i think i'm up three health
i got to get out of here he's running
he's running he's bailing all right push
on him
no it's going all the way no one does
not care i'm distracted keep pushing him
you need to kill me or else we lose
ah dead shot i'm low i'm low i'm low on
low aim on the front one ah i'm dead
chris is out he's pissing me he's on me
no one's on me oh let's get him let's
get him get challenged come on they're
pushing back up back
oh my god we came back yes wow red team
got the dove you guys just want ten
thousand dollar pcs what are you gonna
do with it i'm gonna learn how to play
minecraft better yeah
since you guys got the dump you get to
pelt them fun time
you gotta be better
your secret sauce
hey carl carl last burger